auf und davon
mit der mobilen versicherungen und
vorsorge die vision ist groß der
wasserturm von cuxhaven soll komplett
umgebaut werden dem wassertank ein café
entstehen
das ehepaar gisa hofft auf die
unterstützung der stadt und hatte eine
sitzung mit dem oberbürgermeister
wir sind ganz froh dass sie da sind
zudem bauten sie ihren vintage steuern
zu einem café mobil um über ein jahr ist
es her seit sich das ehepaar sommer von
der schweiz und von ihrem sohn dylan
verabschiedete in ruanda bauten sie ein
fitnessstudio auf wegen corona
verschiebt sich dessen eröffnung aber
auf unbestimmte zeit das ehepaar ist
deprimiert ein hundehotel in spanien das
projekt von chorin und ralf waldburger
kommt nicht auf touren
neben der bürokratie erschwert auch der
nachbar der lieben
bis die lang ersehnte baubewilligung
kommt sucht ralf eine neue
einnahmequellen
[Musik]
es ist bereits die zweite weihnachtszeit
die unsere tore auswanderer in ihrer
neuen heimat spanien erleben
die zeit vergeht und doch scheint alles
still zu stehen
während des ganzen vergangenen jahres
mussten sich die schweizer in geduld
üben
nichts lief wie erwünscht besonders groß
liebsten ralf schlug dieses nichtstun
aufs gemüt
auch das kleine tool haus konnten sie
wegen corona nicht vermieten
aber tötet lange musik macht wählerische
irgendwie ganz anders sich immer so
bedrückt sie und hat überhaupt nicht
geschlafen diesem hamsterrad eine
gefühlt war irgendwie skat und dezember
morgen sitzt nämlich sowohl schöne
sachen machen dass man die spiele nur
das meer aber hoch dass man auch wieder
mutig im moment sind das warten auf die
baubewilligung ist zermürbend
an dieser front zeichnet sich ein
lichtblick ab unverändert schlecht aber
ist wald bo das verhältnis zum nachbarn
noch immer ist seine haltung feindlich
trotz mehrmaligen versuchen schafften
sie es nicht den spanischen nachbarn für
ein gespräch zu gewinnen
damit sie ihm ihr projekt vorstellen
können trotz hindernissen und ärgern
greene will sich das leben nicht schwer
machen sie besitzt das einzigartige
talent problemen spielerisch zu begegnen
ist das respektiven er so gegen ist es
nun der hotel ist mit dem
unsympathischen verhalte und wenn man
mit den steilen weg weit werbung einfach
das herz macht den ich doch dass schönes
erfreut ein
aber es ist so schön da und wenn dies
das nicht vermiesen sind jetzt ganz so
viel locker und von einer anderen
perspektive wenig die jahre selber nach
wie vor zu eng
einen grund zur hoffnung gibt es nun
endlich das gesuch ist bei fast allen
ämtern durch zur überwindung der letzten
hürde treffen sich die waldburger mit
ihrem anwalt um die baubewilligung für
ihre hundepension zu erhalten mussten
sie den behörden ein konzept einreichen
das ist schon mehr als ein jahr hier 200
seiten lang war das konzept nun fehlt
einzig und allein noch das okay des
veterinäramtes diesem amt ist ihr
konzept aber zu detailliert
ich habe noch über ja quasi von der
leitstelle was okay - tg dass da war ich
gewartet das umfangreich es jetzt große
stoß und damals müssen aufpassen für
kleinere version und die zeigen
gemeinsam mit dem anwalt werden sie eine
schlankere version einreichen die
chancen stehen gut dass diese version
schneller das ersehnte und letzte okay
bekommen wird
[Musik]
bei der auswanderer familie davoser in
cuxhaven dreht sich seit über zwei
jahren alles um ihren wasserturm
nun haben sie eine tiefgreifende
entscheidung getroffen es gibt kein café
im wassertank oben 40 meter hoch über
der stadt
die mentale wollen ihr projekt radikal
verkleinern
die vielen vorschriften die
verzögerungen und dann noch coruna
wieder bell und alle mussten die
ursprünglichen pläne aufgeben
[Musik]
das vorhaben wurde immer teurer zu teuer
für ihr budget und das wird die auflage
von richtlinien und aufwändig müsse da
an andere die lösung
und das bedeutet dass mediziner htcs
erstes obergeschoss war die erste
fahrzeug und die detektive honig ist vom
technik das café im erdgeschoss also der
umbau des wassertanks ist somit
hinfällig und auch ein großteil der
brandschutzauflagen den tank wollen sie
jedoch der öffentlichkeit zugänglich
machen
schon bald wollen sie das
redimensionierte gesuch einreichen
[Musik]
in kigali der hauptstadt wann das steht
unseren afrika auswanderern ein
besonderer abend bevor
heute treffen sie nach über einem jahr
ihren sohn dylan spielt in der
ruandischen basketball
nationalmannschaft wegen der
qualifikationsspiele für die
afrikanische meisterschaft ist der
nachtigall gereist
kontakte mit der außenwelt durftet denen
bisher nicht haben doch die chance
dürfen ein training besuchen
noch müssen sie einen moment warten als
sehen sie ihren sohn von weitem sehen
jahr umarmen coruna ist einmal mehr
spielverderber
[Musik]
der 203 cm große dellen trägt die nummer
die linie ist in der schweiz semi profi
und als doppelbürger in der ruandischen
nationalmannschaft engagiert seine
eltern hat er noch nicht entdeckt
[Musik]
dylan wird zurückgepfiffen
sollte sie verloren gehen
[Musik]
erst nach dem morgigen spiel werden sie
sich in die arme schließen dürfen noch
24 stunden
das versteh schon aber eher traurigkeit
nicht aber mehr hände nicht wenigstens
möchten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
erneut bekommt aller die folgen der
pandemie zu spüren
eigentlich verdient der familienvater
das geld mit der organisation von messen
in der schweiz eine großveranstaltung
ist nun verschoben worden
[Musik]
deshalb hat alle jetzt ausgiebig zeit
seit tagen schon entkernt er den turm
der gelernte sanitärinstallateur reist
von badewanne bis küche alles heraus und
schlägt den jahrzehntealten verputz ab
[Musik]
was mir passiert ist leider mit einem
gebot für david noch putzt für uns auch
heute noch so aussieht
im endeffekt noch etwas sehr sehr gern
und die kraft uns alle freut sich ich
werde diese zeit voll grohmann das ganz
kann sowohl die sache
[Musik]
neuigkeiten vom oberbürgermeister haben
die gabe saß noch keine erhalten aber
der denkmalschutz gab nun endlich eine
erste einwilligung an sich fertig jetzt
müssen wir einfach mal startet ein neues
großes statement gemacht hat ein kumpel
hätte das militär 2006 räume machen und
so das vertrauen der sparer und soll
muss verstärker wünsche ist dass es nach
motive geld und das ist ihm egal ob
laptop eine ähnliche gefühle nicht nur
bauschutt
es scheint als befreie sich auch von
angestauten frust
[Musik]
das ist 30
endlich endlich geht es vorwärts
[Musik]
auch ralf ist während des langen wartens
nicht untätig er hat eine firma
gegründet salzburger swiss home service
neuwähler immobilien bewirtschaften und
er hat bereits einen ersten auftrag der
costa blanca nachrichten und der
härtesten luft als inserat mulde und
autos immer noch zu dem motto will er
leider im moment durch das ganze gebiet
spanier chema termin können machen mit
den jetzigen betreuer vor dem aus ironie
des schicksals eigentlich wollen die
waldburger in ihrer pension
hundebetreuung heute müssen sie jedoch
ihren hund den benji abgeben statt
vierbeiner betreuen sie nun
liegenschaften collins eltern passen
derweil auf den kleinen auf das ehepaar
am herd lebt seit 15 jahren im sonnigen
spanien und sie sind immer da wenn sie
gebraucht werden
das berufsethos des havaristen hätte
sich nicht unüberwindbar
zum glück kennt sie so vorgesorgt und
finanziell ist es so dass das know how
und überbrücken
ich bin überzeugt sie werde das meisten
also sie sind jung und
unternehmungslustig und wenn das ein
projekt nicht klappt dann bezahlt ein
anderer sound
da habt ihr also wird das wird schon
werden das wird funktionieren
die guten worte geben den beiden jung
auswanderern kraft und stärke deren
durchhaltewillen
[Musik]
man dagegen südsudan
heute findet in kigali ein wichtiges
qualifikationsspiel die stadt die an ist
aufgeregt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
euro
dylan gibt alles trotzdem südsudan
gewinnt spd ist zurück vier sehr freudig
problem ich gerne aber sowieso das
schönste kommt noch
[Musik]
ich bin gut so
[Gelächter]
endlich denkt
[Musik]
ein take you know how linda vorgeben mir
wurzeln endlich zusammen
aber morgen mittag schon mussten wieder
zurück in die schweiz
auch die gas sind happy ihr café mobiles
nach einem halben sommer umbau endlich
startklar
mit dem café lino auf drei rädern haben
sie angefangen auf märkten verkauften
sie schweizer süßigkeiten und schenkten
kaffee aus
danach werden sie stellt der neue
umgebaute citroën bietet mehr platz
schützt gegen wind und kälte und kommt
bedeutend eleganter daher auch das café
ist exklusiv sie haben eine eigene
mischung sogar geschlossen
der kultige kleintransporter aus den
70er jahren ist eine kleine aber
wichtige einnahmequelle für die familie
und das perfekte werbemittel für ihr
turm projekt
es war der über 120 jahre alte
wasserturm mit seinem potenzial der
familie größer zum auswandern
inspirierte
[Musik]
seit über zwei jahren wohnen sie an der
nordsee ein lebens abenteuer für die
ganze familie
als 2004
die mediziner das gut doch nicht sie
haben die lücke erkennen warum rot für
sie schätze das was mir machen wo ich
als person wert auf jugend habe ich
schon wie viel so sehr fest dass auf das
auto wurden und abo fürs café bauer das
ist schon cool dann mit mir wird es
kostet ja vor damit das mit reserven
oder zum sport ist für die wartung der
jüngere der beiden söhne jannis ist im
letzten schuljahr wohl sonst er möchte
eine ausbildung als forstwart beginnen
der 18 jährige nicola absolviert eine
lehre als hotelfachmann
bald schon werden die jungs aus fliegen
der ton bleibt das projekt der eltern
ich glaube wirklich schade dass so etwas
immer noch damit schweiz zurück nach
maximilian machen das ist das mal
gemacht haben
januar weiter danke mir davon nicht ab
bis die klinge bin name ist nahe und das
ist falsch lag doch jetzt soll system
machen ich kann mich mal zurück
gefängnis ist komisch ist der haut ist
es den und mittellose das verbot sind
[Musik]
die costa blanca ist seit jahrzehnten
ein beliebtes urlaubsziel
viele mitteleuropäer besitzen hier ein
ferienhaus eines davon werden nun die
waldburger betreuen dürfen während
jahren hat das deutsche ehepaar
schnieber diese liegenschaft betreut
altershalber geben sie das mandat ab
[Musik]
peter stieber zeigt den beiden thurgauer
die künftigen aufgaben
und was muss man einfach immer jedes mal
wenn sie bevor sie kommen
saubermachen geschlagen hätten sich
meistens immer vorher an
kann man einen denn die leute ein
bisschen halt die betten gerichtet
werden
da hinten ist noch erzählen auf
wintergarten stellt mir meistens die
schirme aus soja fliegen raus noch ob
das spiel und dem tisch davon genau dass
die wenig arbeit haben wenn sie urlaub
machen cool ist schon wahnsinn hier
alles in den berg gebaut
greif ist ein mann mit großem
handwerklichem geschick der gelernte
autolackierer baute einst sein haus in
der schweiz eigenhändig um die richtige
machen und nicht nominiert die
haaranalyse bis kurz zu machen und in
theres huser können
nein da bin ich richtig
sehr gute wünsche ich viel erfolg
problem hast ruf anja oder fragen hast
ja das macht wie ich komme gerne der
hausbesitzer hat ein grundpaket gebucht
das heißt eine wöchentliche kontrolle
von haus und prüften und pflanzen gießen
weitere arbeiten kann ralf zusätzlich
verrechnen ich denke man hat oder
vorleben aber mein buch natürlich alle
geschafft also mit ein zwei
liegenschaften ist es nicht getan also
umgerechnet und so wenn jetzt ohne
briesen ist auch nix sie bruchsicher
sich unzählige schaffte zogen doch ohne
also überleben zum einfachen leben ich
freue mich dass man diesen ersten
auftrag hand und vor allem eben auf die
zeitung vorlag und womöglich gar nicht
gelaufen ist und mit dem hundehotel
anlauf vor mit mega dass der wald sind
erste auftrag
[Musik]
der unterhalt von ferienhäusern ein
geschäft das sich auch während dem bau
ihres hunde hotels fortführen ließe
in kigali neigt sich ein workshop zum
thema kundenservice dem ende zu ein
berufsverband hat dazu eingeladen
dank seines wissens und seiner kontakte
ist marco der leiter des anlasses der
maschineningenieur hofft auf weitere
workshops nicht nur des geldes wegen die
arbeit hilft ihm hier fuß zu fassen
das gefühl ich sie geht weg von der
schweiz das ganz sicher aber noch nicht
100 prozent die gal das ist irgendwie
komisch schwierig zum ausdrucken aber ja
es fällt posiert und noch immer noch bis
komplette soziale netzwerk hinzu wir
hoffen dass es den ball damals so
wichtig dass ich das jetzt schon vor der
auswanderung wusste marco dass sie von
den einnahmen des fitnessstudios allein
nicht leben können
vor wenigen monaten haben sie deshalb
auf einem dreieinhalb hektar großen
landstück zitronengras angepflanzt heute
ist erntetag zitronengras kann mehrere
male im jahr geschnitten werden
das freie feld hat seine tücken
[Gelächter]
15 leute ernsten während drei tagen
marco will nicht nur genau wissen wie
viele kilogramm die ernte wiegt er ist
auch einer der gerne selber anpackt
das war knapp vor felix felder gehen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
zehn tonnen zitronengras camaro an einen
duft ölproduzenten verkaufen
da derzeit hohes gehalt des grases nicht
besonders hoch ist ist der erlös sehr
bescheiden
trotzdem einige hundert dollar gibt es
[Musik]
dass wir jetzt noch nie wirklich und war
kritisch oder sogar noch mehr abgeraten
gewerk langenberg der angreifer probiert
oder verdünnter so schlecht wenn schon
so schreibt es das 10
[Musik]
im dezember kommt das café wasserturm zu
seinem ersten einsatz am alten hafen
findet ein kulturevent stadt lange bevor
die veranstaltung beginnt sind dicker
busch vor ort bewohner und garstiges
wetter alle zweifel am erfolg des
anlasses
deswegen sehe ich ganz alleine und das
ist mir egal
aber wenn man es probieren mirabel lässt
sich nicht beirren charmant knüpft sie
kontakte trotz wenigen besuchern bei
ihrem citroën hybrid4 noch glück mit dem
maschinenraum müsste ich wirklich reden
die ist noch wie eine effektive arbeit
ist einfach es ist ja gar nicht ja die
sinn fein die tödlich das ist bündner
musste das ist typisch schweizerisch das
ist ein mit walnüssen und sogar
anmeldung ist so lecker
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ja genau
wir wollen schon seit zweieinhalb jahren
wir wollen den waffen die idee geht auf
das gespräch führte augenblicklich zu
ihrem großen herzensprojekt dem
wasserturm
das ist wichtig denn alle an zählt nicht
nur auf die unterstützung der stadt
sondern auch auf deren bewohner wir
jetzt momentan kann mit der sponsoring
mit flaschen steinen
wenn wir ins kabarett vom feinsten
treppenstufe verkäufe damit man diese
kugel finanzieren und das ist finanziert
ich dass ich wirklich große brocken
da hoffen wir schon dass man doch
etliche deswegen war das coaching und
unterstütze dass das ist ganz klar dass
youtube für heinz cuxhaven beispiel 7
das ist zwar kaffee das ist an zwei
hindernisse sind dafür da überwunden zu
werden
die karussells nehmen jeden rückschlag
als neue herausforderung an und nähern
sich so stetig ihrem großen ziel
[Musik]
in ruanda sind die chance eigentlich
schon lange auf der zielgeraden gegen
korona aber dürfen sie ihr studio noch
immer nicht eröffnen
glücklicherweise machte vermieter ihrer
fitnessräume keinen druck mehr
solange das studio geschlossen ist
müssen sie keine miete bezahlen
[Gelächter]
das ist die letzte sache zum aufmachen
wie mache lang sie machen langsam aber
die hoffe wir sind jetzt dran ich hoffe
sie nutzen die zeit und machen fotos für
ihre webseite
durch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ok
noch hat sich die hans lang ersehnter
traum vom eigenen fitnessstudio nicht
erfüllt trotzdem kein grund zur eile
das sollte nicht sonst hätten anderes
machen
also ich habe da nach rom zum wechseln
im leben und
quervergleiche geplant weiter wieder
gefahren und jetzt eine ganz ganz viel
neue erfahrungen machen also
selbstständigkeit job über die jobsuche
die unsicherheit natürlich auf transit
neue leute kennenzulernen neue gebiet
vor allem also doch also für mich und
als belohnung die erfahrung dass ich das
nicht bereuen
wirklich nicht also ich bereue gar
nichts es ist nur nicht ob
sie dürfen also wieder aus
[Gelächter]
mit gelassenheit und hüftschwung
akzeptieren die chance ihre jetzige
situation
und so werden sie auch die zukunft
meistern
hell
[Musik]
auch bei unseren spanien auswanderern
lief vieles anders als gedacht
[Musik]
vorerst gut drei jahren lernten sich
green und ralf kennen ab dann ging alles
rasant heirat nach einem jahr
gemeinsames auswandern nach 2
und dann in spanien stillstand corona
und all die verzögerungen schlagen aufs
gemüt zusammen warten diese erfahrung
haben die beiden noch nicht gemacht dass
man jana mandana
es ist nicht so wie früher
früher wäre ich sehr sehr geduldig sie
aber wenigstens einmal schönes wetter
den wald oder
ein leben mit sonne und meer einer der
wenigen träume die sich erfüllt haben in
diesem schwierigen jahr
einfach süß will man sie natürlich 24
stunden 7 tage sich der auswanderer sind
immer zusammen und da geht natürlich
moment situation aber dann halt nicht so
schön sind aber ich denke wie sie liebt
das aushalten aber schon wie lange
extrem für sie gar nicht
diese bezieht das einmal doch wie
meinungsverschiedenheiten
[Musik]
denn genau
das ist geil
[Musik]
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge